Hi, I'm Ian from
getflight.com.au.
We're a sale airfare search
comparison website.
Basically what we do is we show
you where you can fly for
how much, and we show the
results on a map.
So this is an example
of Sydney to
anywhere for any price.
Let's say we want to go
Sidney to New Zealand.
So what we've now done is we've
zoomed in here to a
channel of flights
into New Zealand.
We're using the Maps
API version 3.
Some of the cool things we're
doing here-- we're using the
geodesic lines to show the
[INAUDIBLE] flight path.
We're also doing server-side
clustering.
So for example, if I drill down
into some flights, say,
here in Asia, as I zoom in,
the server's is going to--
on the back-end, it's working
at the zoom level, and then
it's rendering each label
individually.
But when you zoom back out, we
start to cluster the results.
One of things that I've really
focused on is ensuring that
the same code base works on
tablet and the mobile as on
the desktop.
So here we have an iPad.
So it's the same JavaScript
code that's running this.
And the users can still have the
same functionality on the
mobile as they can have
on the browser.
I've been working with the Maps
API for the last year.
What I really like about it--
I can write for multiple devices
really easily, and I
know that my code will
work on mobile,
tablet, and the browser.
I really like that I don't
have to host the
infrastructure for my Maps,
and that Google will
host that for me.
And I also really like that I
can work with JavaScript, and
I can quickly and flexibly
prototype
things using my browser.
And I don't have to
compile any code
to make things happen.